(upbeat music)
- Hey guys, it's me, Jasmine,
and I am back with more
TikTok recreations.
Last time I made a few vegan recipes.
This time, pasta, baby.
I found two in particular
that I really wanna recreate.
So first we have the succulent raviolis.
I'm a plant mom, I saw these,
and I was like, yes, we're doing it.
Second are these lemon raviolis.
They look amazing.
They are paired with
this lemon sauce filled
with a lemon cheese.
I love lemon anything.
Let's get started.
Honestly, it doesn't look that hard.
I'm gonna eat my words later, aren't I?
(Jasmine panting)
I think I'm losing my mind.
I'm not gonna lie,
I'm a little nervous
because @dannylovespasta
makes it look extremely easy
and some people think I'm clumsy.
So we're gonna start by making the pasta.
We're gonna be making two colors
and we are gonna be using
all natural ingredients
to color our dough.
We're gonna start with 100 grams of flour,
which is about a half a cup.
Now I'm gonna add in the
butterfly pea tea flower.
We're gonna mix this together.
It is blue but once we add in the egg,
you'll see some magic.
So we're gonna pour this
on to our clean surface,
make a little well, add in an egg,
half a tablespoon of oil,
and then continue mixing
and incorporating everything together.
Egg mixes with the blue from
the butterfly pea tea flower.
It's gonna create green.
Right now it kind of
looks like Frankenstein-y,
but it'll all come together.
You can totally use a stand mixer
if you want to make
this a quicker process,
but the portions we're
making are quite small
so I thought it'd be
easier to do it by hand.
So after you roll it all out,
it's a beautiful succulent green.
Set it to the side and I'm
gonna cover it with a bowl.
And then we're gonna make
our terracotta pasta.
It's the same recipe.
We're gonna take our flour
and color it this time with paprika.
Mix it all together,
and now we're gonna pour
it onto our surface.
Use the bowl itself to create a well,
add our egg.
Oh my gosh.
That's so pretty.
It's taking everything in
me to not take a picture.
Oh well, I'll just fight it.
Half a tablespoon of oil,
I'm just eyeballing it.
Now we're gonna incorporate
everything together.
The color is already forming.
It's so pretty!
Whenever I do make pasta at home,
I'll make it with my stand mixer
and I'll make it in large amounts.
Mixing it all together
is a lot more satisfying.
Feels like I have to, you know,
put in more love and care into my food,
and I like that.
So same thing with this.
We're just gonna knead this
until everything comes together
and after you should have a dough
that looks something like this.
Same thing.
We're gonna set it to the side
and cover it up with a bowl
so a crust doesn't form on the outside.
Now it's time for decorating.
Oh my God, I'm really excited.
Oh, dang it!
Never mind, it's time to roll it.
Start with the green dough.
I'm gonna flatten it with
my hands just a little bit.
We're gonna put it
through our pasta roller.
(mixer whirring)
We're looking to get
that perfect rectangle
before we actually roll things out,
just to make our lives a little easier.
We're gonna do this a couple more times
so it's nice and smooth.
Oh my gosh, it's so beautiful.
All right,
we're gonna do the same thing
with our terracotta dough.
Beautiful!
I see you, Danny.
All this hard work for a short video.
All right, we got both of our doughs here.
They look so pretty.
I'm scared to touch them.
Danny's starts with this pasta cutter.
We're gonna press this but
try to avoid the bottom.
It looks good.
Okay, yeah.
So I'm gonna put the
triangle below the point
of the top to do some window spacing.
Must be precise.
Okay, the filling is gonna go
on that bottom portion there
so we wanna make sure we
don't cut through that.
Okay, that looks pretty good.
Now we're gonna connect these lines here.
I'm scared!
This is fun, though.
Unless I mess up, then it's not fun.
Oh yes, the top layer is good.
Wow, if anyone's gonna do this at home,
do not drink caffeine, okay?
'Cause my hands are so shaky.
Look at it.
It looks very unimpressive
right now, but that's okay.
I'm gonna set this to the side.
I'm gonna start doing them vertically
so we can get more succulents out of it.
Yes! I did it.
Each one has taken me about three minutes.
When I take the time to actually
make sure it's done well,
I have more fun.
I think that's something you have
to keep in mind even
when it's frustrating,
so don't take it too seriously.
All right, I'm gonna do this last one
and then we'll move on
to the terracotta pot.
All right, so what we're gonna do
to create the terracotta pots,
I'm gonna cut them vertically
about an inch thick
and then a small little thin strip
to create the lip of the pot.
It's really hard to keep these moist
and when that crust forms, ugh, doomsday.
Switching tools.
Nice, so much easier.
I like holding my hands stable.
Perfect!
One, two, three, four, five.
I can't believe we made it to this point.
It is time to fill our succulents
and then assemble them.
So I have here a cheese filling.
It has Parmesan, ricotta, an
egg yolk, basil, and garlic.
I'm a little scared, but let's do this.
I think that's good.
I'm just gonna roll one up first
because I wanna see if that
filling level is correct.
We're gonna fold over one side of the leaf
so we can get that window spacing
so we can see all the leaves.
Oh my goodness.
I'm obsessed already.
I'm gonna leave that first
and fill the others before I roll.
Huh, huh.
(Jasmine panting)
I'm just gonna fold it over
and then I will adjust these.
Okay, it looks like I didn't do
the window spacing good enough.
You know what?
Maybe it'll look better rolled up.
It's so hideous.
(Jasmine exhaling deeply)
Yes!
We've done it.
We've done it!
Magic.
Last one.
This one I gave the most space
so I'm gonna add a little more filling.
Wow, I got a hang of it, y'all!
Cute.
Okay, so I'm gonna pinch the sides just
to make sure no filling escapes.
Are you ready?
Now what we're gonna do
is roll up our succulent.
The filling is everywhere, oh no.
It's kinda cute.
Brent just went.
Oh no, it's so ugly!
A for effort?
They're actually pretty cute.
I don't mind the filling there.
I think once they're all assembled
and standing together
they'll look really good.
I'm just hyping myself up.
You gotta be your biggest
supporter, remember that.
Now for the last one, look at that.
Biggest takeaway is that
you've gotta leave enough space
for the filling.
This one was the thinnest and
this one was the most spaced.
Okay, so now that we have
that, we have our terracotta.
I'm gonna brush this with
a little bit of water.
It's gonna be our glue.
Oh my gosh, it's so cute.
I love it.
I'm just gonna fold down the bottom
so there's none hanging out
and I'm gonna take, ugh, it broke.
Now we're gonna place this lip
and just line it at the top
of the terracotta plant.
Oh, there's a little bit of
space left because I broke it,
but that's okay.
Is it cute?
I have to learn to not
be so hard on myself.
It's so easy to criticize
and self criticize,
but remember you're just
having fun in the kitchen.
At the end of the day, you're
eating pasta so don't be sad.
Them two next to each
other is really cute.
Gonna take a little bit of water,
just spread the leaves a
little bit, rehydrate them.
Okay, yeah.
This is definitely the cutest
one, but you know what?
These aren't bad.
Like altogether, they look very cute.
It's like my little garden.
Our pasta's complete,
it's time to cook them.
Let's see if all this was worth it.
I'm a little worried that
they're not gonna hold its form
but we're just gonna roll with it.
I don't know how long
exactly to cook them for
so we'll check intermittently.
Oh, so cute.
I can't help it.
I have to take a picture.
Smile, freddies.
And now we wait.
These are ready.
Oh my gosh.
They're so cute.
Okay, so we're gonna take these out.
Oh, I'm surprised they held
their shape very, very well.
Honestly, I can't believe
we made it this far.
We are gonna do the sauce.
We're gonna keep it very simple.
We're gonna add a little bit
of melted butter, some salt.
I'm scared to get too rough with them.
I don't wanna mess up the leaves
because they're already
a little wilted and sad.
I'm just gonna plate these.
I wanna 'em all bunched together
because that's what my garden
would probably look like.
We're gonna finish this by topping it
with some grated Parmesan.
And here they are.
The succulent raviolis.
I'm hoping the taste will make it worth it
because I spent a lot of time on these.
They're not very pretty.
I just want them to taste good now.
It's finally time to try it, y'all.
Cheers.
I like it, Picasso.
I really like the flavors a
lot, but the ratio is off.
I would definitely add more filling
but I can tell it would be good
if it was drenched in more sauce.
Looking at mine and looking at Danny's,
I wish I didn't compare them.
I have to say it ends up being worth it
because I had a good time making it.
I think this is a good warmup.
Let's move on to the next one.
We're making a lot of pasta today
and it's the same recipe
for the most part,
so I'm just gonna show you a bunch
of pretty clips of me making the pasta.
I won't bore you with the
step-by-step details yet again.
(slow funky music)
(Jasmine yawning)
The sun has risen,
birds are chirping,
and our dough is finally complete.
We have our beautiful white dough.
That'll be used for creating
the wedges as well as the pith.
We have the lighter yellow
for the inside flesh of the lemon,
the darker yellow for the outside.
Let's see, we start with
the lightest yellow.
Trying to follow this but it goes so fast.
So I've layered my dough.
I'm gonna do full lemon
slices on this side
and as it gets narrower
I'm gonna do half circles
to get wedges.
My circles look good.
I feel like we're gonna get a
lot of pasta out of this one.
All right, let's do a
little bit of cleanup.
We're gonna shave off the sides here.
We got lemons!
It's time to fill them.
We have so many raviolos today.
Wait, no, these are ravioli.
One is raviolo, right?
No one knows.
Please tell us the answers.
5 plus 5 is 10, plus 4 is 14.
14 divided by 2 is 7.
I have seven ravioli
and I'm gonna start by
brushing some water along
the edges of the round.
Okay, so I just rewatched the video.
I messed up.
She makes it like regular ravioli.
However, I cut them all out first
because I'm really good at directions.
But that's okay because I was
able to do the calculations
to get the right amount
of lemon plus the wedges
so we reduce food scraps.
I am just using a lemon
whipped Burrata here.
This is the same one
that @saltyseattle uses.
All right!
Let's press them down.
I've already put water on them
and just squeeze the outside.
Oh God.
(Jasmine panting)
My second one looks great!
Okay, so I'm putting in
the center and I'm pressing
from the filling outwards so
that there are no air bubbles.
I would say if you're scared of error,
to reduce that margin of error,
to just use less filling.
But then you have less filling.
Choose your character!
I choose flavor.
So now we're gonna make the segments
of the lemon using our white dough.
I'm just gonna cut thin white strips
and I'm just gonna keep doing
this until I have plenty.
Brush it with some water.
Okay, so now we're gonna
do eight total segments.
I wanna make sure it's
pressed down all the way.
Great!
Okay, that looks pretty good.
I'm just gonna keep doing this until all
of them have their segments.
Be right back.
This is gonna take a while.
Now we have gotten all our wedges.
It's time to make the pith.
The pith is the white part of the lemon.
Very bitter so when
you're zesting your lemon,
you never wanna zest the pith.
Okay, now I'm gonna do the rest as wedges.
Yes.
Yes!
This is winning, people.
I have all my circles cut out
and to make the pith I have
to use this smaller cookie cutter,
place it in the center,
and cut out the middle.
Okay.
Wow.
I'm just hoping it'll look cuter later.
So I'm gonna continue doing this
and I'll be back for the rind.
So we got a problem.
I have the wrong size cookie cutters
and the size I have would
overlap the pith entirely.
However, if I use one that's too big,
there's nothing to glue on to it.
So it would just be hanging out like that.
That is a no go,
so what we're gonna do
is use the same size
but we're gonna wet it with our water glue
and then just kind of situate
it in a place that works best.
I have an idea!
I have an idea.
I'm gonna roll them out!
Yeah!
Can we get a clap sound effect here?
(crowd clapping)
Oh my gosh.
We freakin' did it.
I'm so happy!
Yay.
Orange.
I'm so proud of this.
Mimo, Mimo, come here.
- Oh my gosh, you did it.
- Isn't this so cute!
- So cute.
(both cheering)
- Yes! Bye, Mimo.
She's going to sleep now.
I'm gonna keep doing this
and I will be right back.
It's the evening now, in
case you're wondering.
I've been waiting for this moment
to cut off these little diggly poppers
that are poppin' out of the orange now.
Okay, I'm gonna start with the wedges.
These have been taking so long
that when I just pressed down on it,
it crunched.
Oh, they're coming apart.
We're gonna finish these up
and then we'll get to boiling.
I think I'm losing my mind a little bit.
The TikToks are like so
short and it took me all day!
I can't believe we're at this point
but we are gonna cook it.
Salting my water first and
my water has come to a boil.
Now I'm just gonna gently
place them in with my hands.
I'm gonna scoop it out with a spoon,
drain it on my spider.
Yes!
Everything stayed together!
I am very impressed.
I'm also quite tired,
but I'm very impressed.
Now that our ravioli's done,
we're gonna toss in
this garlic cream sauce.
Gonna top it with some
peas, some Pecorino cheese.
Ooh, that looks good.
Some salt and some lemon zest.
And here we have it.
Lemon ravioli.
I would charge $300 for this.
More maybe.
This is like my midnight
snack, but I'm really excited.
A lot of TLC went into this.
Let's give it a try.
Mm.
I'm very happy now.
It was all worth it in the end.
So lemony, so garlicky, so creamy.
Was it worth it?
Honestly, yes, it was worth
it because I got to make it.
I have a finished beautiful product.
Things went a little off course.
However, look at it.
Gorgeous.
If you guys end up making
any of these pasta shapes,
make sure to snap a picture,
tag me on Instagram,
because I wanna see it.
Thanks, guys.
Bye.
Oh, yes.
(Jasmine laughing)
Let's go to title card.
- [Man] Oh, yes!
(slow funky music)